[Applauso]
[Musica]
nel 2003 il pugile campione del mondo
dei pesi massimi Mike Tyson dichiarava
bancarotta con 30 milioni di dollari in
debiti lo stesso Mike Tyson nel corso
della sua carriera aveva accumulato
oltre 300 milioni di dollari
negli stessi anni Ronald Read l'ha detto
alle pulizie di un grande magazzino di
Vermont investiva mese dopo mese i suoi
Modesti risparmio
quando Ronald è passato a miglior vita
l'intera cittadina dove viveva non
poteva credere che avesse lasciato
dietro di sé un patrimonio di oltre 8
milioni di dollari 8 milioni di dollari
con il modesto stipendio di un addetto
alle pulizie
Chop in una domanda sul denaro stesso
Ma che senso ha affannarci così tanto
per accumulare il nostro gruzzoletto se
poi se poi il vero problema sembra
essere la nostra capacità di gestirlo se
non sai gestire mille euro non saprai
neanche gestirne 10.000 non saprei
neanche gestirne 100 mila o un milione
imparare a gestire i propri soldi e
è un super potere è un superpotere che
ti aiuta a smettere di preoccuparti dei
soldi
Io ho iniziato la mia carriera lavorando
in una grande banca d'affari
una banca da fare di wall street e
lavoravo negli uffici di Zurigo dove
gestivo i soldi di alcune delle persone
più ricche d'Europa
il mio lavoro consisteva nel far fare
soldi per persone che già avevano molti
soldi che non era proprio una missione
umanitaria così entusiasmante
da un lato mi rendevo conto di quanto i
mercati finanziari fossero la più grande
macchina di creazione di ricchezza della
storia umana dall'altro lato però mi
rendevo anche conto di quanto fossero
riservati a pochi quando parlavo a
persone a cui volevo bene
mi rendevo conto
che non sapevano da dove iniziare mia
sorella che è seduta lì a fianco a voi
mi diceva cose che sapevo essere
sbagliate come che si investe per
diventare ricchi che investire è uguale
a speculare che forse la cosa più
responsabile che possiamo fare è tenere
i nostri risparmi nei conti correnti
aspettando di poterci comprare una casa
ed è per questo che allora sono passato
a lavorare in una società Tech dove
faccio investire le persone con la
stessa efficienza di prima
Solo che adesso faccio investire anche
chi Magari non ha 500 milioni di dollari
da parte
quanti Quanti
di voi in questa sala hanno voi o la
vostra famiglia un patrimonio di oltre
500 milioni di dollari alzate la mano
la Lazio Io per esempio non è non ho 500
milioni di dollari
Quanti di voi Voi o la vostra famiglia
avete un patrimonio di oltre 100 mila
euro
quanti di meno
se la matematica non è un'opinione più
di qualcuno non ha alzato la mano ho
visto
tante facce come questa
ma
Ci avete pensato se sono stati
guadagnati in maniera onesta e dignitosa
Ma che male c'è a dire a quanto ammonta
il nostro patrimonio quello nostro della
nostra famiglia
in Italia ci vergogniamo
ci portiamo dietro
la cultura medievale del denaro Come
vile come sterco del diavolo parlare dei
soldi in Italia è più imbarazzante che
parlare della propria vita sessuale ma
oggi parleremo proprio di sesso no di
conti correnti
e Bisogna parlarne anche di sesso
Bisogna parlarne ma oggi di conti
correnti
parleremo di conti correnti perché
questo silenzio ci impedisce di capire
come gestire i nostri soldi in maniera
efficace Forse è per questo che 7
italiani su 10 sono analfabeti
finanziari pensate che paesi come la
Nigeria
o la Bulgaria conoscono più in termini
di gestione dei soldi di Quanto
conosciamo noi forse è per questo che la
cosa che più amiamo fare Forse l'unica
che sappiamo come fare con i nostri
soldi a tenerli a dormire nei conti
correnti però vedete il denaro non dorme
muore a poco a poco giorno dopo giorno
una banconota da €5 sempre una banconota
da €5 Rimane però l'inflazione si mangia
ogni giorno il potere d'acquisto dei
nostri risparmi pensate che 100 mila
euro lasciate nei conti correnti dopo 30
anni possono diventare la metà della
metà
e poi poi c'è
una leggenda una leggenda che per tanti
di noi questa sala è meno credibile
di un unicorno la pensione
e non è una novità che in Italia Abbiamo
un sistema pensionistico che è sull'orlo
del collasso e che l'inflazione ci sta
mangiando i nostri soldi però quando
apriamo i giornali leggiamo il problema
problema e non le soluzioni come se ci
dovessimo rassegnare all'idea di avere
il nostro denaro mangiato e dover
lavorare fino all'oltretomba facendo
sacrifici su sacrifici su sacrifici che
poi diventano
diventano sacrifici di una vita intera
una soluzione però c'è
e alla stessa soluzione che le persone
più ricche al mondo conoscono e fanno
ogni giorno
investire non vuol dire speculare non
vuol dire giocare in borsa non vuol dire
comprare solo Bitcoin
vuol dire prendere il nostro pezzetto di
crescita economica della Società
il nostro pezzetto di progresso
economico ora senza mettermi a fare
queste frasi così complicate Quanti di
voi e spero che ora vi vergognate di
meno rispetto a quanto quando vi ho
chiesto Quanti soldi avete Quanti di voi
hanno un iPhone in questa sala
vi vergognate meno eh
Quanti di voi hanno azioni di Apple in
questa sala
da quando è uscito l'iPhone le azioni di
Apple sono aumentate di 8 volte la
maggior parte della sala Ha pagato per
l'iPhone ma non ha beneficiato della
crescita economica della Società e la
stessa cosa succede quando comprate una
coca-cola a Barra succede quando pagate
la bolletta della luce di Eni
investire vuol dire diventare socio di
queste aziende e prenderne parte ai
risultati economici
anche le case che a noi italiani
piacciono quanto ci piacciono le case
pensiamo che il mattone sia sempre
sicuro con poche decine di euro tu puoi
diventare socio di aziende o fondi Che
investono nell'immobiliare aziende fondi
gestiti da professionisti che comprano
intere palazzine le ristrutturano per
poi venderle o affittarle così puoi
diventare
poi agli stessi vantaggi di mettere in
affitto una casa però se se si struttura
il bagno o se si allaga il pavimento il
problema non lo deve risolvere tu
ora al contrario di quanto si pensi per
investire non serve né essere Un
economista né avere tanti soldi ci sono
alcuni semplici principi semplici ma
fondamentali
che ci aiutano a investire bene io
come forse vedere dalle mie occhiaie ho
passato migliaia e migliaia Come forse
tanti di voi migliaia e migliaia di ore
sui libri di Finanza e in mezzo a
grafici e formule ho capito che questi
principi sono ben più importanti
rispetto a tante altre cose oggi voglio
darvi i tre che per me sono i più
importanti numero uno prima di investire
capisci dove vuoi andare
Definisci i tuoi obiettivi perché non
esistono investimenti perfetti esistono
investimenti migliori o peggiori a
seconda di quelli che sono i tuoi
obiettivi vuoi avere una rendita da
affiancare lo stipendio vuoi proteggere
i tuoi risparmi dall'inflazione hai un
qualche obiettivo che vuoi raggiungere
tra 10 o 20 anni
prima Capisci quali sono i tuoi
obiettivi
e poi inizia a investire
numero 2 investire bene e semplice è
semplice ma non è facile il motivo per
cui non è facile siamo noi stessi
diventiamo il nemico numero uno dei
nostri soldi perché ci facciamo prendere
dalle emozioni
ci facciamo prendere da Euforia quando
Vediamo i mercati salire su e ci
facciamo prendere dal panico quando li
vediamo andare giù
in questo caso come vi sareste sentiti
no
fa male alla pancia vedere i nostri
soldi
i nostri sacrifici giù prendiamo il
giornale panico parliamo con la persona
a fianco a noi ancora più panico
Questo è quello che è successo dopo
da dopo il 2008 i mercati sono saliti di
oltre 400 per cento e la volatilità è
una parte normale fisiologica del
mercato ma
guardando un'ottica di lungo termine i
mercati hanno sempre fatto una e una
sola cosa sono cresciuti insieme alla
crescita economica c'è stato vero
Nonostante guerre mondiali nonostante
pandemie nonostante crisi finanziarie e
continuerà sempre essere vero
però capisco che fa paura
per iniziare a investire possiamo fare
iniziare con poco e aumentare man mano
che siamo a nostro agio per farlo C'è
quella che per me è la più grande
rivoluzione finanziaria dai tempi del
bancomat si chiamano piani di accumulo
in etf ma ora Ora mi sta finendo il
tempo e c'è il terzo terzo e ultimo
consiglio forse più importante
iniziate adesso
preferireste ricevere oggi Un milione di
euro
o un centesimo un centesimo che
Raddoppia ogni giorno per 30 giorni
centesimo 2 4 8
l'ultimo giorno questo sarebbe risultato
5 milioni e mezzo è l'effetto
dell'interesse composto Einstein lo
chiamava l'ottava meraviglia del mondo
dicendo che chi lo capiva ne beneficiava
e chi non lo capiva lo pagava negli
investimenti si ha quando investo Anno
dopo anno i profitti e diventa come
come una palla di neve che scende dalla
montagna che scendendo scendendo
scendendo aumenta sempre di volume prima
Inizio a investire più ne riesco a
beneficiare
però vedete per quanto Per quanto ricco
Ronald Read non ostentava mai i suoi
soldi girava con la sua Toyota Yaris di
seconda mano
aveva un cappotto che era tenuto insieme
da una spilla da balia
però aveva un sogno aveva il sogno di
aiutare le persone a cui voleva bene
ed è per questo che quando è passato
miglior vita La maggior parte di quegli
otto milioni sono andati all'ospedale
della sua comunità
Ronald era un uomo ricco ma non perché
fosse ultra milionario
mia sorella che ha sempre seduta lì a
fianco a voi
investe mese dopo mese i suoi risparmi
sa che i suoi soldi stanno lavorando per
lei e lavorando per aiutarla a
raggiungere i suoi obiettivi e penso che
forse se più di noi facessimo come lei
sarebbe un mondo un po' più informato
un po' più equo e forse forse
sarebbe anche un mondo un po' più felice
è sì perché se è vero che
i soldi non danno la felicità e anche
vero che ci aiutano a raggiungere i
nostri sogni e i sogni Come direbbe
Shakespeare sono la materia di cui siamo
fatti Grazie
[Applauso]